one little final follow-up from the
weekend cpac
this is sarah palin
sarah palin is fascinating we have
covered sarah palin for a really long
time because back in 2008 she was the
late senator john mccain's vice
presidential running mate and at the
time she became known to us
for her incomparable word salads and her
abject failure at using language to
communicate she just couldn't do it she
you saw her mouth moving you heard
things coming out some of them were
words but it didn't fit together in any
way that made sense it's sort of like if
you made a dish for dinner and like you
see a plate
and you're aware that there's pasta
in the toilet and you saw tomato sauce
on top of the fridge like individually
these are elements of food but it's not
coming together in any way that makes
sense now similarly when sarah palin
appeared at cpac over the weekend
she was um
apparently trying to quote
uh
abraham lincoln
and she is so visibly confused and so
incoherently trying to use language that
i don't know what the hell she's talking
about it also looks like she has a
massive gaudy star of david hanging from
her neck i mean every aspect of this is
whacked and whatever is going on with
her seems to be getting worse and worse
maybe she was referring to a lincoln log
i don't know but this doesn't sound like
anything i've ever heard lincoln say
person what they're doing is usurping
the the power from the other two
branches of government the judiciary and
the legislative branch we can't allow
that to happen things like that that
that um create this atrophy in the
foundation of america will destroy
america's like lincoln said we're not
going to be destroyed from foreign
forces coming on in it's going to be
from within if we allow things that are
so
anti-constitutional um to um
to be able to use sir for instance the
balance of power so yes uh dan sullivan
is right you know is she talking about
abraham lincoln because i don't what she
she said it's like lincoln said
that let's really analyze it's like
lincoln said
we're not going to be destroyed from
forces coming on in
it's going to be from within if we allow
things that are so anti-constitutional
to be able to for instance usurp the
balance of power
i guess she means we must protect
ourselves from domestic threats
more than foreign threats is that am i
succinctly summarizing what she meant
there
um i don't know
i genuinely don't know but sarah palin
continuing to visibly struggle to use
the english english language to
communicate